tonight football player henry ruggs the
third wheeled into court to face justice
this is the case of the state of nevada
versus henry james runs the third the
wide receiver fired from the las vegas
raiders wearing a neck brace charged
with multiple felony counts including a
dui in the fatal high-speed crash the
police report on the fiery wreck saying
ruggs was driving at 156 miles per hour
my health
yeah for everyone who's not in america
you want to do the conversion miles to
kilometers that's like 240. but have you
seen where the cars were that was in the
city that's crazy with the blood alcohol
level twice nevada's legal limit before
slamming into another vehicle killing a
woman and her pet defender's vehicle
struck the rear of the victim vehicle
such violent force that it ignited the
fuel tank
23 year old female occupant and her dog
died as a result of the fire the
wreckage and cones showing the erratic
turns the car made before impact the
judge remarking extreme speed was
involved i cannot recall a speed that
high
in my career on the bench judge
bonaventure rejected the prosecutor's
request for one million dollars bail
rug's bail set for 150 thousand dollars
and the highest level of electronic
monitoring he was also ordered to
abstain from alcohol and other
controlled
tony rodriguez did not hesitate jumping
right in trying to save a life i thought
for sure we're going to be able to do
something the fire was so small at that
time
and
it just it grew fast
really fast
there was one person here with a fire
extinguisher a county worker that didn't
work it wasn't enough
it was just so fast i was
she was still breathing
everything we tried it just
wasn't working
and the fire just grew so fast and she
was actually still alive she was you can
hear her breathing
and she had her seatbelt on and i was
trying to cut that away and i just
couldn't and
i was trying to do everything i could
you know for
trying to grab them by the the shoulders
and pull them out and that wasn't
working they were pinned
the seat belt was on the airbags went
away the door was jammed it was
minutes seemed like hours had been at
least maybe more than 10 minutes
and it felt like a lifetime i mean
rodriguez wished he could have done more
the pain of a life lost so hard to take
i'm sorry i tried i tried everything i
could and
my friend as well
i'm sorry
it's something he'll never forget you
said
you had her blood on your hand yeah
yeah after noticing that that's when i i
had actually left the scene and uh
i went home to go pray for her that's my
girlfriend
he got released though
i think on bail 150 000
it would be nice to have all that money
you know my son wanted to go to the
stadium watch the football game and i i
just
i was going to go for a concert next
year and i don't think i'm going to go
you know it's so you're permanently
gonna have just like terrible feelings
about anything allegiant anything
raiders yeah i still haven't slept since
the accident
you know it's just horrific you know
first off to the reporter who's trying
to instigate something that's the
reporters man that's the reporters so
you're not going to feel anything
positive about them really a man just
lived through something super traumatic
and you're a fighter trying to find out
who he got beef with you know what i'm
saying there's something distasteful
about the line of questioning to me you
know one thing is that find i find like
the the reporters nowadays are really
not reporters
they're really influencers
trying to instigate [ __ ] trying to
that's what they're doing that's really
what they're doing it's not the job
change man the job changed but it's
really yeah i feel you on this one you
know so so
the man in question henry rux andy ruggs
is uh he was recently drafted by the
oakland raiders projected to go really
far in his nfl career doing really well
for himself as a young man and
he made this terrible decision
and it's interesting
how
that recklessness right because he had a
woman with him in his car and they got
into this accident both of them survived
the other woman who was in the other car
and
the dog died
it's interesting
how much that one decision branches out
to everybody
right it's like she dies
the people who try to save her
was hard
or scarred traumatic right you can't
sleep you can tell like the amount of
guilt right survivor's guilt is a real
thing and then her family who lost her
whoever she's connected with
losing that and then he's no labor to
provide for his family it's like a it is
a
big time decision yeah it it
it escalates quickly and there's just
nothing positive about it it's
incredibly tragic
we were we were chilling on one of my
rides with different boys right it was a
bike night and we went from one point to
another point and we was driving
at some point i was in my t-rex and the
guys were on the on their two wheels
and at some point the guy starts
tracing after that they told me that
they thought they saw the cops but i was
like okay so what bro tracing that means
that they were zooming these zoom zoom
right i stayed back i'm like i let them
go
but i was following one of the
[ __ ] at some point he goes like
like his wheel goes like that
and he keeps on going like that while he
was chasing on his bike
he caught a flag it's not even
necessarily the other sometimes
sometimes it's your own bike you go fast
you
you you you you didn't do the
maintenance on your chain your chain
snap you're in the middle of the road
you don't have all that
it's it's it's crazy and then you have
you know we live in montreal so we have
the roads how up they are they don't
maintain it like other places and then
there's other drivers that are
that's it's it's yeah it's
speed is something
speed kills right no
no speed has never killed someone
is stopping very abruptly that does
but yes he does you know being an adult
is not an easy thing
we say it all the time right it comes
with a lot of privileges
but
ooh you know uncle ben says it right
yeah accountability also comes with a
lot of responsibilities and um i have no
problem with him being held accountable
for his decision
he's an adult he made an adult decision
and i had adult consequences
and so he should suffer adult
repercussions
we are not seeing anything that hasn't
already been said right in regards to
don't drink and drive like i can't tell
you how many times i've had to tell
people this how many times i've had to
slap keys out of people's hands so like
friends of mine who's trying to go home
drunk i'm like bro let me pay even when
i was like struggling let me pay because
this is stupid
okay
and i hope that you guys were watching
at home also take this in
you have people who love you maybe you
don't want to hurt others don't do it if
you see your friends doing it don't tell
them not to try to stop them if you can
it's crazy because when you
from understand when you drink the
people that drink and drive you when you
drink you get into this phase where
you good
that's the thing your judgments get very
impaired you know i mean it's not just
everything else you know it's your
judgment
and you really think you're good you
really think you can do this you really
think you know what
i'm fine
i'm fine every people that i have to
slap the keys from their hands
they really think they're fine they
really think they're okay
what i'm the opposite i think i'm [ __ ]
up
like
i'm like not [ __ ] i can't walk straight
is it because you
you don't do it as often you see me when
i was on stage 12 [ __ ] up i was like
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] up
i'm very aware of the fact that my
body's not moving the way that's
supposed to move yeah right maybe it's
because i didn't mean nothing there's
something weird where you do a
coordinated step and you're like oh
wait but i don't think it's about that
me neither what my whole point is
i think people the way that they behave
when they consume alcohol varies from
person to person i could never do the
whole drinking and driving thing because
every time i've ever gotten drunk i've
always been like i'm i can't do it right
so i think it just varies for personally
but you think you think i i don't think
it's really about the fact that they
know or they don't know that they're
moving they know it's like you know
when you have your dad or someone or a
friend that's on the couch
and then like
you change your channel because these
[ __ ] sleeping
and like i sleep in bruh bruh ruff you
know you're sleeping
i know you you're doing the whole
i know you're stuck no i was sleeping i
was leaving what happened movie
but it's the same mo when you're drunk
it's not about not knowing that it's
really another thing that they know they
can do this or no i'm not sleeping no no
i was not this no i was not that i'm not
sleeping no i'm good now i could do this
no no you know you know you're sleeping
you know so it's just it and i think
that i think that alcohol amplifies that
and then you
so really
all is to say i really don't have the
answer to that i don't know how many
times we have to say it and stuff like
that i'm not saying that we're immune to
that and everything and stuff that
cannot happen to me or whatever but
it's it's yeah decisions
it's just decisions it's a sad sad
[ __ ] story yeah but you know i'm not
gonna get into like what drives a person
do that because i think there's so many
permutations as to reasons why it could
be anger it could be you wanting control
it could be you wanting to be reckless
and self-harm it could be ego it could
be a various amount of things you know
and you know i can't sit here and kind
of analyze the the psychology of some
why someone would do it i just tell
y'all at home don't do it
you know don't especially if you know
that you're prone to really terrible
decisions when you drink maybe you don't
drink
that's something a lot of you also have
to acknowledge yeah not everybody can
handle everything not everybody should
smoke weed no okay
not everybody should drink alcohol nope
that's a fact and so knowing that
i would just tell you guys just to try
to be responsible right because there's
a lot of people counting on you there's
a lot of people counting on other people
that you may hurt um and i think we
could all do our part in that regards by
just ensuring that because of so many
people who die from drinking and driving
every single day every single day people
drink and get behind the wheel you know
there's a young lady that was in the car
with him yeah
what if she told him not to drive
we'll never know but you know what i
mean that's like hypothetical okay i'm
not saying this is their case i don't
know me personally
if i'm with my girl and she's drinking
and she gets behind the car [ __ ] we not
going nowhere neither are you that's not
gonna happen that's not happening
and this man had like twice the legal
limit apparently in terms of alcohol
he was all [ __ ] up so the people
around him if you see that your boy or
your girl your compromise you also gotta
get in on that but also if you care
if you care but also alcohol works in
this serious way so if you drink you
drink you drink your drink
and you're not
twice the limit when you leave the bar
it's by the time it hits you you know
what i mean but by that time you already
drank you know i mean he was not at zero
when he left the bar so
if you see your people if you yeah
just don't do it it's it's really this
just don't do it yeah
i don't know i i just wanted to kind of
bring this up and share the story with
you guys uh and to the man and it's
something i got just for the man so you
know the man who you could tell is
clearly
clearly severely affected by what he saw
and and i got to tell myself that as
well yeah it's something that we all
have to tell itself i'm not saying that
like i'm from a high point like i'm
better than all you it's something i got
to tell myself as well because it's very
dangerous for my part because
you see me drink it doesn't affect me as
much but
everybody could have a bad day you
didn't really drink you didn't really
eat or whatever what not again you have
to be aware of that and it's really a
question it's really serious yes i agree
all right well listen that's it for us
in today's video let us know what you
guys think in the comments below we want
to hear from you